hello everyone welcome to my video
series of
mall bio explained in three minutes
where i explain a concept of molecular
biology in less than three minutes or so
if you haven't yet subscribed the
channel hit that subscribe button
in today's installment we'll talk about
touchdown pcr
so touchdown pcr is not a totally
different type of pcr
it's just a modification of the existing
pcr protocol
now in this protocol the initial
annealing temperature
is higher than the optimal annealing
temperature
and gradually it reduce to the optimal
temperature this enhances the
specificity and yield
of these pcr reaction so this touchdown
pcr
you utilize all the similar reagents
that we use in normal pcr reaction the
difference lies in the program
in a moment we would understand how this
program is set
and this touchdown pcr is comparable to
the touchdown of an
airplane now you have seen how airplanes
land right
they gradually decrease their altitude
and then
land on the runway now in touchdown pcrs
similar things
happen so in touchdown pcr
they gradually decrease their annealing
temperature until they reach their
optimal temperature
so the pcr cycle is like this there
would be initial
10 cycles where in the annealing step
there would be a decrease in temperature
each cycle
the temperature would decrease and the
later half
would look like any normal pcr which
would have that
optimal annealing temperature and lastly
the pcr would be done so the main step
is this initial 10 cycles
each cycle reduces the temperature
to let's say one degree and in 10th
cycle
this particular pcr reached its
optimal temperature for primer annealing
now what's the advantage of these kind
of touchdown based approach
let me tell you clearly so once
touchdown pcr is
performed there are few advantages
first of all if we have very low
annealing temperature
then there could be non-specific binding
of the primer and primer dimer formation
and if we have too high annealing
temperature even specific interactions
won't be
so much perfect that is why there would
be low yield
now in touchdown pcr what happens
initially
since the tm is high then
only highly specific primer and template
pairing
is allowed and the non-specific
interactions
that might occur are actually
avoided at this higher temperature so
these non-specific binding does not
happen
when the temperature is pretty high
right in short td pcr
reduce the probability of non-specific
binding
and at the end result instead of getting
a smear
you get crisp bands nice yield in the
pcr
so the overall advantage of doing a
touchdown pcr
is better specificity and better yield
lastly this pcr technique is just a
modification of the pcr program and it
doesn't require
additional expensive material so it's
cost effective
and it saves your time so next time you
are thinking about
low yield and one specificity try
touchdown pcr
now if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up you can support my
channel in patreon
if you're an indian viewer you can
support my channel via vmwpi
and as usual like share and subscribe
you can also take my
academy course using code ap 10 you can
get a 10
discount thank you